so
the organizers asked me to talk about
fine-grained hardness in cartography
you did and
naturally i said i said
uh what are you talking about uh we
we barely understand coarse grain the
hardness
in cryptography and anywhere else but
unlike avi
i like to do what the organizer is
asking me
so i said okay give me your shortest
slot and i'll tell you everything i know
about
um okay so i'm going to talk about
two research directions that
are widely open i think are very
interesting
they're open for more than 20 years it's
there's been a little bit of work on
them
in the last 20 years but not as much as
they deserve
so to begin with i'll talk about the
notion of proof of work
and which will talk about moderately
hard puzzles
and then i'll talk about
how hardness is born how hardness can be
created
and how can it gradually increase
and i guess that was the reason for my
other title
it's getting harder all the time okay
so crypto we have alice and bob
ellis has a randomness
on our side and a security parameter
k and the kind of puzzles were used to
talk about in crypto are very hard
puzzles
so alice can create a puzzle send it to
bob
and the creation of the puzzle is very
easy it can be
linear in in the security parameter
linear in k
and verifying a solution to a puzzle can
also be
very efficient but solving the puzzle
should be infeasible should be extremely
hard
you can't do it by in any polynomial
time
and and many times we would ask for it
to be much harder
sub exponentially hard exponentially art
and so on
um and
these kind of puzzles are also known as
a one-way functions
and there is an a beautiful theory
around them
so this is the the coarse grained
hardness we talk about now moderately
hard puzzles
and we talked about it through this work
on
spam fighting by dworkin or
and they suggested the following
solution to to spam fighting so let's
say bob wants to send an email to alice
the problem is that sending an email is
so uh
cheap that bob can very well be a
spammer and very cheaply send
a lot of of emails around and and spam
everybody so instead what alice would
ask
bob to do is to say okay send me the
email but only after you solve
this puzzle that i created for you so
now to send the email
bob will first need to solve
the puzzle and then if the puzzle the
solution verifies
then alice will be ready to read the
email
so solving this puzzle
can no longer be infeasible because we
do want to allow
email communication to go through but it
should be moderately hard
and so it should be hard enough
so spammers would really be hit
by computing by having a lot of
computation
but regular communication shouldn't be
disturbed by much so we need
very good bounds we really need to
understand
how hard it is exactly hard because we
need both the lower bound and the upper
bound on the hardness of this
puzzle and
in addition we shouldn't be able to er
to amortize the computation because if
bob is a spammer
he doesn't care about solving one puzzle
you need to solve a lot of puzzles
and we want to make sure that solving a
lot of puzzles is is still very hard
so there are various natural candidates
for this
and um and in fact this can be also
non-interactive so
we don't need this kind of pattern of
communication
so spam filters actually have improved a
lot since this
very very early work on spams so perhaps
we don't care about it anymore
but there are other other applications
denial of service time commitments it's
it's a
very basic aspect of of all these uh
digital coins in a sense what you're
having is something
your coin is something that's hard to
compute that requires some work to
compute
that's the worth of the coin
and there are various interesting
questions so dwarf and already asked
this question
can all of these puzzles be part of
something we really care about
why waste all of this computation effort
uh on on things that we don't care about
and this perhaps is an analogy to
something that
was done much later in the in the
context of
verifying that the a human
is is interacting with the computer so
this recaptcha
is actually using a lot of these inter
small interactions
to solve things that we really care
about like digitizing books
but the main question which i i'm
raising here
and they raised 20 some years ago
is is there a rich theory to uncover
somehow in a similar to the rich theory
that we have when we start with hard
puzzles so on these art puzzles we can
build a lot of other things
can we connect different things that are
just moderately hard and still useful in
cryptography
so that's the one question that i wanted
to raise
and for the other uh let's talk about
this beautiful theory that's built over
one wave functions
so in cryptography where many times we
start with this building block
for example let's say one wave functions
and from these building
blocks we construct something else
something very beautiful perhaps some
beautiful protocol that solves a
difficult problem
and these constructions come with a
reduction
that proves that if this is secure
then what we constructed is secure and
this security comes with
a parameter let's say r so you are
secure if in time
r you cannot solve it better than with
probability one over r
or whatever it is but the main thing
about
all of these security reductions
uh is that they always decrease the
hardness
so r prime is always smaller than r
and that's why i call it hardness
reductions it's not only the secure
you reduce the security but you also
reduce the hardness
and uh
and so let's take for example factoring
which could be an example for these
puzzles
so factoring is a problem that was born
hard
cryptographers did nothing to make
factoring a hard problem
it was it's immediately hard and what
cryptographers have been doing
all along is make out of this hard thing
other things that are a little bit less
hard this is one
way that we deal with with hardness but
the other question that i wanted to
raise
is uh can hardness be
constructed can it evolve
and that really that connects
um to a to
a conjecture or even a thesis by charlie
rockoff that i'm going to
describe in the next two slides so and
and this is in the context of block
ciphers so very briefly
and a block cipher
gets a key and given a plain text
you produce a ciphertext so this is a
block cipher
for any fixed key this function
is actually a permutation which is very
useful
if you want to go back from the
ciphertext to the plain text
and for a random key this permutation
looks random it is indistinguishable
from a random permutation
so these are block ciphers
and and in reality
unlike this factoring that is
immediately very hard
this kind of creatures are created
by composing a lot of permutations that
are very simple
relatively simple and definitely very
weak from a cryptographic point of view
but this is starting with a aes
sorry with dez and and and and
and all the way to our days
so a very old
uh conjecture or this is by charlie
rockoff
is that if you take any sufficiently
rich
family of of permutations
af and
and essentially in sufficiently rich i
think
he mainly wanted it not to be completely
linear
so if you compose a lot of linear
permutations you stay within linear
permutations
so when i talked with him ages ago
it was about four permutations that he
had in mind
and one of them was non-linear and this
made it sufficiently rich so the idea is
that when you compose it
you can create lots of interesting
functions
independently but much later i think
made basically the same conjecture
but it's more specific right so
he made the subset of this conjecture
let's
yeah let's it will be here so let's wait
uh
so uh so if we take these simple
uh permutations and we compose
polynomial
number of those you will get a a block
cipher you will get a pseudorandom
permutation
so no matter what family you have
as long as it's rich enough whatever it
means you can
get a pseudorandom permutation by
composing many of those
so here something very very simple is
going to be
to gradually become more and more
complicated
and in the 20-some years uh
since and perhaps he had this conjecture
many years before he talked with me i
assume
there's been a little bit of progress
the progress was
that this is a way essentially you can
get similar things
uh in a similar way you can get ky's
independent permutations
not pseudorandom permutations by k but
[ __ ] independent permutations
and and sorry almost k ways
so the fam the simple family of
permutations that they considered
so gowers and and later
juliet al the simple family was one
where you look at let's say
your input is n bit long you select
three
beats so this defines one of eight
values
and you have some all the permutations
on these
eight values so you only touch three
bits and you
permute the val the value that you see
in these three bits
so very simple each one of them is very
very easy to break
but if you compose polynomial number of
those
you get k y's independence since it's
almost what we want
uh but the order of quantifiers is
different
uh while we want to compose polynomial
number of
of permutations that will be secure
against any other polynomial which may
be
larger here for any fixed polynomial
number of queries if we compose a larger
polynomial
it will be secure so it seems like we're
close but
probably not as close as we want
and and there are lots of questions to
be asked
what about so the random permutations uh
is there a relation can we say that if
one family
is if we have this congestion for one
family does it imply the conjecture for
another family
and uh and in general how hardness
evolved in crypto
is interesting we do have other
simplifications but in a very different
notion
sense doesn't work on card shuffling
have some bearing on this so there's a
result of
percy diacomas that's seven shuffles of
a certain kind are enough to get around
them
right so so this is very closely related
to
card shuffling uh in some of the card
shuffling
that they were considered a lot of
pieces are moving together so even the
simple prompt
so the question is how simple is this
basic shuffle is and this shuffle is
extremely simple because
only eight cards are moving at a time
i think the point is you can't vote by
this kind of mixing
process to actually convert to a uniform
permutation
right because you don't have enough
information to describe
a uniform permutation right right so
in a sense this so i said why this is a
bit weaker than what we want
but it's also stronger so it's
incomparable because we're not shooting
for
being statistically close to uniform
we're shooting to be
in this indistinguishable so
it's not about mix it's a markov chain
but it's not about mix
it's me it's mixing when you when you
fix your
when you fix your attention only on on
these
on on k cards it will it will uh
their location will mix so if this is
the sense of mixing is the cake almost
give us the only
interesting test function or do you
really want
like another speaker
no no we do i mean i want any any
polynomial time test
but this is the only thing that i'm
aware that we know how to do
it's not the result uh oh so here is an
another
final conjecture that's much more
concrete
and that that was made in this paper
uh is it the case that the moment
so take any family any small family
fermentations
the moment you compose enough of them to
get four ways independence
is it the case that by now you also get
pseudorandomness so this is an extremely
concrete conjecture i like the thesis
it's very
very difficult
right right so as we
we can prove almost anything so we just
reduce one thing to the other so
i gave these
assumptions uh
that's a great question so that i guess
because it's hard
and it explains why there's a little
progress but
i think that actually some of the
reasons i don't want to get into it some
of the recent work on
on uh this small grain complexity may be
a little bit encouraging
in terms of the kind of assumptions uh
but
i would start with this question about
the relation between different families
there's one family
let's say if you're contained or or
containing doesn't imply another family
or
yeah i don't know if i had them i knew
about it for a while and they didn't do
anything
you could definitely try to refute them
right i mean these the last conjecture
seems very
last conjecture yeah that's very natural
exactly